What would happen if every microbe in the
world just...disappeared.
Could we live?
Could anything live?
And for how long?
First, let’s talk about mass extinctions.
The first microbes on this planet appeared
billions of years ago.
In the long history of life since then, researchers
have estimated using fossil evidence that
there have been five major mass extinctions.
These extinctions were catastrophic mixes
of geological, biological, and of course on
at least one occasion astronomical issues
that, over the often protracted period they
occurred, killed off a large percentage of
extant species.
The end-Permian extinction, which is considered
to be the largest mass extinction, occurred
over 252 million years ago, the result of
volcanic activity that produced greenhouse
gases and warmed the planet.
But more recently, researchers have identified
another potential culprit: microbes.
Specifically: methanogens, a type of methane-producing
archaea whose numbers may have increased as
they fed on dying plants and animals, creating
even more methane that warmed the planet further,
killing more organisms, producing more food for methanogens
A classic positive feedback loop that changed
the planet too fast for many species to cope with.
Now, this idea that microbes may have been
involved in the largest mass extinction is
a hypothesis, rooted in scientific observation
but still not proven but, as we look at what
a world without microbes might be like, remember
that they may have, at least once, done living
systems a good deal of damage all on their
own.
But a world without them would do far
more damage.
With this thought and perhaps our own biases
in mind, the collective scientific understanding
of microbes feels a little bit like being
in love.
It wasn’t long ago that we didn’t know
they existed.
But now, it hard to imagine a world
without them.
Now, this has not stopped scientists
from trying to imagine such a world.
In 2014, Jack A. Gilbert and Josh D. Neufeld
published a paper in PLOS Biology called Life
in a World without Microbes, envisioning a
hypothetical world where in a single moment,
all microbes vanish.
Their thought experiment uses what we’ve
learned of microbes to take on a belief put
forth by Louis Pasteur, that, “Life would
not long remain possible in the absence of microbes.”
and that may have been the case then, but we have more technology now.
There are many ways to explore
this hypothetical world without microbes,
and in their work, Gilbert
and Neufeld consider what we might broadly
group into two questions.
What would an absence of microbes do to the
world around us?
And what would an absence of microbes do to the
world inside of us?
Let’s start with that second question: the
internal one.
If all microbes, single-celled and multi-celled,
were to vanish, there would be a large number
of diseases that would just cease to exist.
Now, in this hypothetical, mitochondria and similar
endosymbiotic prokaryotes that have long been
integrated into multicellular, eukaryotic
bodies such as our own, are treated not as
microbes, but as part of our bodies.
If all mitochondria disappeared, do not fear,
you would be dead that very instant.
But even without endosymbionts that leaves
many, many microbes inside of us, particularly
bacteria in our gut that aid in digestion
and metabolism.
It’s unlikely that we’ll ever know for
sure what would happen to our bodies if all
of those microbial residents were just suddenly evicted.
The examples we can take from various
types of germ-free animals that have been
raised since the end of the 19th century suggests
that life, at least inside of us, will still
go on—it’s just not clear what that life
would look like for us.
We would likely have to rely on synthetic
nutrients to compensate for changes in how
our body processes food.
Meanwhile, our own physiology might change.
We would, for example, be smaller,
having access to fewer nutrients.
leaving us to wonder what of our body belonged
just to us after all.
But of course there are many, many microbes, in fact the vast majority of them,
existing outside of our bodies as, and a hypothetical microbial
banishment would create some clear challenges.
You might think that, without the work of
diatoms and other photosynthetic microbes,
we’d be at a risk of dying from a lack of
oxygen pretty quickly
And yes, it would be an eventual problem.
But it turns out there is enough atmospheric
oxygen to sustain life for a pretty long time.
Gilbert and Neufeld note this as more of a
centuries-long back-up plan
while we can maybe figure something else out.
But, if we're being honest with ourselves, we probably wouldn't make it that long.
There are larger problems.
Some bacteria, like Nostoc, convert diatomic
nitrogen in the atmosphere
into other nitrogen-containing
compounds that plants can actually use.
Their disappearance would severely reduce
photosynthesis, and yes, limit the further
release of oxygen into the atmosphere, but also,
it would just make it much harder to grow plants
which, you will remember, we need for food.
Meanwhile, macroscopic decomposers would have
to take on much more of the burden of converting
death into new ingredients for life.
And we would also feel the loss of other cycles
that rely on microbes, like the processes
that move phosphorous across different layers
of life.
The interlocking nature of these microbe-based
processes within their environments mirrors
our relatively new understanding of how our
microbiome dictates the interplay between
microbes and our bodies.
In fact, scientists have begun studying what
they call the Earth Microbiome.
not just a catalogue of the diversity of microbes
across the planet, but a broader understanding of
how the microbial composition is its own dynamic
thing that shapes and responds to the world around it.
There is an ongoing conversation about the
possibility that we are somewhere in the midst
of a sixth extinction event driven primarily
by our own human actions.
The characteristics of this extinction are
much more readily observable on animals and plants
than on microbes, but they are an important
piece of that extinction puzzle—both in
terms of their future and our own.
Many microbes, after all, seem readily capable
of survival—like the trusty tardigrade,
the mascot of all microbes who do what we
would all love to do when conditions are bad,
they curl up in a protective cyst and lie dormant.
The question, if that really is what it will
to take to survive, what will the world
look like when they wake up.
At the end of “Life in a World Without Microbes,”
Gilbert and Neufeld describe a world where
nutrients and resources become increasingly
scarce--a world where we would need to rapidly
fill the void left by microbes with manufactured
alternatives designed to fill in cavernous cracks.
They argue that we might actually do okay
for a few days, and maybe a small number of
humans would manage to last even for centuries.
But in the long term, for us humans at least, the
prognosis is bleak.
But they also point out that while microbes
play a massively important role in our world
right now, there is a hypothetical where
other organisms adapt or evolve to reconfigure
those essential niches.
Perhaps we would be gone, but life exceeds us.
And so does its capacity for invention.
And then, we suppose, Earth would just have to get ready for some new species to come along,
develop technologies and look into the fossil
record to find what caused our mass extinction,
and then make an internet...and then internet
videos about us, and how weird our world was,
back when there were microbes.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And also thank you to all of these people,
our patrons on Patreon,
who allow us to go on these deep dives
and understand more of how much we rely on these little organisms.
So various and so delightful.
If you want to see more from our Master of Microscopes James Weiss,
you can check out Jam and Germs on Instagram
And you want to see more from us, here at Journey to the Microcosmos,
you can find us at YouTube.com/microcosmos